la ecuación y es igual a 3 x entre 49
intersecta al eje de las 10 en el 09 y
bueno cuando decimos que intersecta el
eje de la yes estamos refiriéndonos a
qué es lo que pasa cuando x vale 0 y si
te das cuenta cuando x vale 0 entonces
esta parte de aquí es de 3 x / 4 esto de
aquí se hace 0 y por lo tanto solamente
me quedaría con este más 9 por lo tanto
interceptamos al eje de ayer en el punto
0.9 y lo podemos ver de una manera
sencilla reescribe la ecuación para
expresar x en términos de yemen x es
igual y bueno como no podemos trabajar
aquí entonces déjame sacar mi libreta de
apuntes perfecto para poder trabajar
este problema y esencialmente como lo
que queremos es reescribir la ecuación
para expresar a x en términos de gem
realmente lo que necesitamos es despejar
la x aislar x
por lo tanto déjame copiar esta ecuación
que abajo para poder trabajar y me va a
quedar antes
poner esta herramienta me va a quedar
que que viene bien es igual a 3x ok
entre 4 ya esto le sumamos 9 ya esto le
sumamos 9 ahora si lo que queremos es
despejar a x lo primero que voy a hacer
es restar 9 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación para que este 9 se vaya del
otro lado hoy lo cancelamos de este lado
derecho por lo tanto voy a restar 9 de
este lado y de este lado también voy a
restar 9 date cuenta que lo que estamos
haciendo es que de este lado derecho más
9 menos 9 se van a cancelar déjame
dejarlo bien y de este otro lado va a
pasar el 9 con signo negativo y por lo
tanto me va a quedar que en que menos 9
antes que me ponerlo con este mismo
color de menos 9 es exactamente igual es
exactamente igual a 3 x entre 4 entre 4
ahora se me ocurre quitar este 4 de aquí
y para quitar este 4 qué te parece si
multiplico todo por 4
a esta parte por 4 ok pero también voy a
hacer lo mismo del lado izquierdo para
que se mantenga en la ecuación voy a
multiplicar esta parte por 4 y es más
déjame mover un poco mi pantalla vamos a
mover un poco la pantalla para que para
que pueda multiplicar por 4 así que
multiplicamos esta parte también por 4 y
de esta forma 4 y 4 se van a ir y me va
a quedar que 4 y déjame ponerlo aquí 4
que va a multiplicar alguien menos 9 que
va a multiplicar hay menos 9 menos 9
esto es igual a 3 x esto debe de ser
igual a 3 veces x y ahora nos falta este
3 este 3 lo voy a pasar del otro lado
dividiendo de ambos lados entre 3
entonces vamos a dividir este lado entre
3 y voy a dividir también este otro lado
entre 3 por lo tanto este 3 y este 30
nails y solamente me voy a quedar con x
que es justo lo que quería
x es igual a 4 que multiplica al menos 9
todo esto dividido entre 3
por lo tanto antes de que se os olvide
lo voy a apuntar justo acá en mi
navegador de internet déjame traerlo por
acá y 4 por yemen 29 entre 3
lo voy a apuntar justo aquí justo aquí
me piden que maneje esa misma
información entonces lo voy a poner 4
que multiplican a de menos 9 ok y todo
esto estaba dividido entre 3 no es así
perfecto ya tengo aquí cuánto vale la
ecuación para x como expresara x en
términos de gem ahora lo que nos
preguntan es cuál es la intersección con
el eje x de esta ecuación y para esto
déjenme regresar de nuevo aquí a mi bloc
de notas para que lo podamos trabajar
ahora esencialmente esta ecuación de kim
se ve de la siguiente manera nosotros
sabemos que esto esto es una recta por
lo tanto se vería más o menos así si yo
la gráfico me va a quedar algo así este
es uno de mis ejes este es otro de mis
ejes déjenme poner que éste
ok estoy muy bien y por aquí tengo a mi
eje x ok y bueno siguió graficar a esta
ecuación sabemos que es una recta que
intersecta aquí en el valor de 9 al eje
de la siesta así que si la dibujamos con
otro color déjame tomar este color y
bueno si te das cuenta tiene pendiente
positiva y por lo tanto es una recta que
se ve más o menos más o menos así se va
a ver más o menos así me afecta y bueno
quiero que te des cuenta que cuando
nosotros nos fijamos en la intersección
con el eje de la jr
estamos hablando de cuando x es 0 es
decir nos referimos a este punto de aquí
pero si yo me quiero fijar en cuál es la
intersección con el eje de las x bueno
estoy pensando en cuánto vale 0 cuando
él vale 0 es cuando nos subimos y
bajamos es decir me estoy refiriendo a
este punto de aquí y por lo tanto lo que
tengo que hacer es de esta ecuación de
aquí ver cuánto vale x cuando vale 0
déjame borrar esta parte de aquí que
solamente nos estorban voy a quitar todo
esto que ahorita nos sirven y solamente
me voy a quedar con
x antes de quitar todo esto de aquí me
voy a quedar con que x es igual a esta
expresión de aquí y yo lo que quiero ver
es cuánto vale x cuando james es igual a
0 y ahora sí si sustituimos ayer por 0
me va a quedar 4 x menos 9 entre 3
déjame ponerlo aquí cuando es cero
entonces x es igual a 4 que multiplica
al menos 9 ok esto dividido entre 3 y
bueno puede dividir 9 entre 3 y me queda
3 ok
4 por menos 3 es lo mismo que menos 12 y
bueno tienen mucha lógica con lo que
veíamos aquí en la gráfica cuando vale 0
x vale menos 12 o lo podemos poner aquí
estamos en el punto menos 12,0 y es más
vamos a escribirlo de una vez en nuestro
navegador de internet déjenme tener para
que la página a donde están
tengo justo aquí y entonces déjame
escribir que cuando x vale menos
12 ok valdés 0 estamos en el punto menos
20 y es hora de comprobar respuesta de
lujo estamos bien